das russische sicherheitsunternehmen
kaspersky lab hat den wohl
schrecklichsten trojaner für android
geräte etwa aufgespürt eine software
namens sky go free die schon seit 2014er
unwesen treibt mit ihr lassen sich
android geräte regelrecht fernsteuern
wie gefährlich ist das programm wirklich
werden auch deutsche user ausspioniert
und wie könnt ihr euch effektiv schützen
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle info
herzlich willkommen bei klicks um
science-fiction sky go free kann nicht
nur whatsapp mit lesen sondern hat noch
47 weitere funktionen und die sind
selbst für experten und expertinnen mehr
als erschreckend auf facebook und skype
beispielsweise sind nicht sicher und
kann mit gelesen und kopiert werden und
jetzt haltet euch fest sky go free kann
sogar unbemerkt euer smartphone mikrofon
einschalten sowie die frontkamera für
videos und bilder nutzen ja also ein
wichtiger grund um sich einen
mechanischen schutz für die kamera
zuzulegen und der hatte sich ja schon
auch standort kalender sms und anrufe
listen werden ausspioniert in einigen
fällen müssen die opfer zunächst
berechtigungen erteilen damit die
spionage funktionen greifen und der
trojaner die gewünschte informationen
bekommt dort kaspersky kann sky go free
auf huawei geräten beispielsweise sogar
noch nach dem ausschalten weiterlaufen
mit recht fragt euch jetzt sicher ob wir
auch betroffen seid achtgeben muss man
tatsächlich auf websites die so aussehen
wie die bekannte mobilfunkanbieter auf
diesen extra präparierten seiten wird
man aufgefordert das smartphone zu
aktualisieren bzw neu zu konfigurieren
dabei installiert sich sky go free auf
dem gerät an den benutzer geht dann eine
willkommens nachricht wie diese raus
sehr geehrter kunde wir aktualisieren
ihre konfiguration und sie wird so bald
wie möglich fertig sagt wie das ganze im
detail abläuft ist aber noch nicht raus
jedenfalls zeigt das alles mal wieder
auf ein neues erst einmal nachdenken
bevor man auf unbekannte links in mails
klickt oder dubiose daten anhänge
geöffnet oder wenn sich eine webseite
öffnet einfach bestätigen
denn auch ein wenig entwarnung gibt es
bislang wurde es nur auf android geräten
entdeckt aber auch windows phone sind
wohl nicht ganz sicher darauf deuten
code schnipsel in einigen modulen hin
die das sicherheits forschungsteam von
kaspersky aufgespürt hatte kleine
bemerkung am rande wenn ihr es nicht
schon längst organisiert euch eine
vernünftige antiviren software für euer
smartphone bislang ist der trojaner
allerdings nur in italien aufgetaucht
hier wurde obwohl entwickelt
wahrscheinlich von einem italienischen
unternehmen das unter anderem auch an
staatlichen überwachungslösungen
arbeitet im klartext könnte es sich also
um einen staatstrojaner handeln mit dem
der staat die möglichkeit bekommt mehr
oder weniger verdächtige personen zu
überwachen ist reiki ist nur ein
einzelfall wenn auch ein ziemlich
perfide
welche viren und trojaner und so weiter
kennt ihr die wirklich so ein ausmaß an
schreibt es in die kommentare
dann machen wir ein special dazu
übrigens könnt ihr jetzt auch mitglied
bei klicks um hier auf youtube werden
das seht ihr unter dem video mit einigen
vorteilen und es werden mehr wenn ihr
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollte dann hättet mich
bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die etwas
unzuverlässige abend box hier auf
youtube und die verpasst kein video denn
über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen technik
garantieren einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks und social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken computer werden 1000 mal
schneller
bis dann bleibt dran und ansonsten das
pfeifen ist beim nächsten oder
übernächsten mal den weg